Patrick sartan he's gonna be the best
corner it's only been two players that
I've ever seen they didn't have a rookie
season they just went straight to year
two Patrick certain and Jerry Judy those
two guys from Alabama I don't know what
they doing at Alabama but those two guys
they came ready to play Patrick certain
if not by the end of this year the next
year he's going to be the best
cornerback in the game boy that boy has
the technique that they teach you work
technique in practice you work your
pedal in practice it looks so smooth you
look like a drill guy hit a comb bang
I'm doing my thing that boy looked like
that on Sundays like how the coach would
coach you to do it in a drill that boy
looked like on Sundays against DK
Metcalf against anybody he dealing with
against Debo he not tripping he's a
cover corner he come up and played a run
two he come up and Tackle he's not
scared to tackle he can play in the slot
man Patrick certain is a real deal and
I'm happy to announce that I am the
President of the Patrick certain fan
club you know so if you ever need shirts
some merchandise Patrick sartan is the
real deal